Sorry.
Excuse me.
There are people we encounter who
changed the trajectory of our lives.
Richard was one of them,
but let me start from the beginning.
It was the first day of college and you
know what that's like. Hi, I'm Mandy.
Mandy,
Mandy.
Yeah, that's me. Sum it
up. I was a nerd. Yup.
The type of near that builds extra credit
molecules for the first day of school.
Did you catch that? That's Natalie.
Well, we'll get back to her later. Hey,
let me help
your freshmen
first lesson in college.
No where you're going.
Where are you headed anyway?
Needless to say,
it was a rough first day of school,
but for whatever reason
Richard was nice to be done.
Yeah. Finish last week. Did
you do phone 15 by any chance?
You know the one was the falling
methyl methacrylate. Yup.
Cause you want me with that one?
To be honest,
I don't exactly remember will be tossed.
But here's the important part.
During natural like this, do you want to
be a rocket scientist or something? No,
actually I want to work
at a software company.
I actually interned at one last summer.
I'm jealous. That's my drink. Over time,
we became good study buddies
and eventually great friends.
Richard encouraged me to be more confident
and to step outside of my comfort
zone.
Remember Natalie?
This covalent bond deals here.
It's about right,
right Andy. Andy. Oh yeah.
That's great. I mean, that's
right. Second to girl, isn't it?
Who is it? Silver. The blue.
One of my classes. Don't be so obvious.
She's cute. She could talk to her.
I want to know what to say.
Well,
let's start by telling her about
your Pokemon card collection. Really,
he thinks she didn't like that. That was
just a job. Never tell anyone about that,
ever.
Why don't you start by introducing
yourself and never really talked to girls.
Andy, you're, you're like
one of the best guys. I know.
You can't really do it.
Turns out not only was really nice and
also need to help with the Oregon homer
spray.
Everything else starts to fall into place.
Hey Richard, I got that interview for the
internship at your company. That center.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Richard. I'm terrible at interviews.
All right, let's try this one more time,
but I also learned that change
is never easy. So Mr. Park,
why don't you tell me why you
want to work for this firm? Well,
I guess because I always wanted to use
my engineering background to help others.
All right. Now tell me about
your leadership experiences.
I don't have any. Yeah,
I wouldn't say that,
but actually that's fine because they
know you're a freshman and you don't
really have that many anyways.
But you know, that reminds me.
Have you ever thought about running
for Engineering Study President? No.
This is my last year as president and I
actually think you would do great job.
No, I don't. I don't run for anything if
dude, it's not a problem. Um, you know,
I think you're well qualified. You're
passionate, you're super smart. You know,
you helped me with my
homework all the time, dude.
We can even make flyers and hot buttons
with your face on it and no, Richard,
I'm not going to run for that. Can
we just get back to this? All right.
What would you say are
your greatest strengths?
Well,
I guess I'm good at engineering.
You're good. I engineering.
Dude. That's a terrible answer.
Try it again. Seriously. What do you
think are your greatest strengths?
Should, I don't know, Andy, can you
just think for one second? I mean,
I can think of 10 things you're incredibly
good at and you came and think about.
One, just help me out here. We've been
doing this for two hours. I'm not you.
I can't be present. I can't
do this interview. Okay.
Funny thing about life is greatest fear
is often allowing ourselves imagine what
we can become.
I never showed up for the interview. I
was afraid of failing, but to be honest,
I was more afraid of letting Richard down.
Okay.
It's Richard. I'm a senior and a couple
weeks and you haven't been in class.
Just wanted to check in on you
and later realized that Richard only
pushed me because he saw something in me
that I hadn't seen him myself.
I can vouch for him.
He's incredibly smart and
he's a really great guy.
Please interview him for the summer
internship. Just give them a chance.
His belief in me inspired
me to believe in myself.
So I decided to take a leap of faith.
Hey,
need a hand.
There are people we encountered who
changed the trajectory of our lives.
Richard was one of them.
I wouldn't be who I am without Richard.
Very special person. Over the past year,
I've gotten to know this guy really well,
and I've had the privilege of forming an
incredible bond with him as his mentor.
So that's why today I'm extremely proud
to introduce him for the first time ever
as the next president of the
engineering society. My close friend,
Andy Party.
Thanks Richard.
I want to start by just
thinking everyone here today go.
How much of a privilege or greatest one
is someone who inspires to be what? No,
weekend.
Uh,
yeah.